so I believe you've launched trailer
hitch under the umbrella of cinefix yes
is that right and you tell us what role
cinefix is played and what impact they
had on the successful farm well cinefix
is the premium youtubechannel dedicated
to film or basically it's it's it's the
channel it's dedicated to movie lovers
and also filmmakers and the idea is to
create programming that's going to
appeal to you know movie geeks like
myself and also people maybe make their
own movies and so it's like anything
it's like trying to come up with
material that appeals that will speak to
that viewer and so we have a whole bunch
of different kind of shows i mean the
two sort of like trailer hitch is sort
of like is definitely more of a comedy
based observational sort of comedy show
you know but it's funny it was born out
of like the fact that trailers for
movies that are coming out are sort of
like available to us that we want to
promote what's coming out but it's sort
of even though we just put trailers up
it's not really adding any kind of
editorial editorial voice to it so that
says so I thought it would be great to
sort of and that's what really would be
vison butthead mike judge was basically
like I'm at MTV we have all these videos
running them anyway why don't we stick
these two crazy losers on top of it and
have them like talk about it and that's
essentially the the idea behind trailer
hitch is to have like two different sort
generations of movie lover one slightly
younger play by myself and one slightly
older play by Allan Havey and and so
that's where that idea came out of it we
also have badass digest which is devin
faraci 'he's successful website which is
really all about movies and movie trivia
and movie facts and i almost want to say
like you know almost like fanboys cinema
when you're dealing with with with with
very specific genre films and and very
detail-oriented very much something that
speaks to the movie geek we thought
which I consider myself one of
um and now Devon goes out and he
basically hosts the show where he brings
his website to life where we'll go and
sit down with ryan Johnson the director
of looper in Bob burns basement Bob
Burns's like the foremost archivist of
all great cinema sci-fi and horror props
like he has all the props from all the
great movies he has you know all the
alien Jim Cameron's aliens and he has
you know gizmo from gremlins and he has
you know the American Werewolf in London
and he has he has the original King Kong
armature you know Peter Jackson G so we
will go to a place like that and show
people like wow look at all this great
stuff look at this man and sit down
interview this man whose preserved all
this stuff and then at the same time
will maybe bring ryan Johnson he
directed looper who's also a geek and
he'll chill see this world for the first
time and then we'll talk to him about
looper and time travel movies in front
of like the original time machine which
bob has like the original George pal you
know broad Taylor time machine so it's
like it's trying to bring this sort of
like and I use this term lovingly you
know film geek culture sort of to life
and so we were doing a whole bunch of
shows like that hopefully will end up
doing script it shows as well but it's a
it's we're we're brand new you know
we're a brand new channel and we're just
I'm just trying to get out stuff that I
think stuff that I would like to see you
know and I think that's the only thing I
can do is try to create programming that
I think you know I would hopefully want
to sit down and watch and and then maybe
people will also you know watch it watch
it didn't take an interest but it's
weird trying to navigate that that whole
space and it's not easy it's like saying
well let's just make a bunch of programs
you know that's that's really we also
have been Lions coming and hosting a
show called screen addict which is sort
of like a show that sort of everything
that's going on in the week and film so
it's a very active it's a very active
channel or constantly producing you know
so it's it's so interesting very hectic
like a newspaper like putting
newspaper
you